before we go any further i have to let
you all know that this video is
sponsored by best buy hello everyone
alana here and today i'm in my brand new
office
it's still
pretty empty which is why there's an
echo sorry about that as i eventually
get more stuff in here that will get
better which is part of what i'm doing
today we're not giving you a tour of the
office just yet let's see bits of it
today i'm going to be doing sort of like
a whole unboxing plus setup video of
three new things that i've been meaning
to check out to get my gaming setup a
little bit of an upgrade now that i have
more space which is just just the best
so yes i have three things here to show
off thanks to my partners at best buy
who are sponsoring this video this video
is sponsored by best buy and i'm excited
to open up these boxes so let's do it
shall we
first things first just something i've
been in dire need of which is going to
be helpful for
any of you pc gamers
but it's also very helpful for video
editing and i'm going to be using this
thing to edit this is the wd black sn850
nvme gaming ssd giving you supreme pcie
gen4 technology of your pc or your
laptop at 7 000 megabytes per second 7
000 so you don't lag out on the next
generation of games
let's open it up shall we
oh it's so sleek
focus
focus
there you go
sorry about my nails everyone
very sleek and should be very very easy
to just plug into my pc especially
because my pc is open case so
love it i'm very stoked to have this
next up is a new pair of headphones
these are astro 850s i realize i should
say the full title here it is astro a50
wireless headset plus base station for
playstation which i have always been a
really big fan of it's a nice
box got your details on the back nice
and shiny very sleek apparently i'm very
easily impressed with packaging
but yeah one thing that's really cool
about the 850s is they have literally
designed them with like
long term
gaming sessions in mind
and these guys are compatible with both
pc and ps5 which is going to be handy
for my setup here
a box inside of a box also very nice
let's open it up
i like them
okay let's try one shall we
oh this is super comfortable
love this microphone bendy
very good
these are obviously wireless completely
wire free but they're also very
lightweight and supposedly deliver top
of the line acoustics
ergonomics and durability for serious
gamers that's me
serious gamer yeah they're very nice
i also have my cable here in the box
this part
is extra cool this is my first time
owning one of these
this is um an astro 850 wireless base
station it has lots of good plastic to
peel off you ready
[Music]
this is very cool you've got a little
switch here from pc to ps4
usb says your ins and outs
got aux there and also micro usb this is
so cool
and that is how they will sit so this
whole setup comes with a mix amp feature
which is especially cool just low
latency voice communications adobe audio
and optimized chat levels and game
sounds with built in mix and technology
very cool it's just really pretty i like
it a lot
it's gonna look great on my show
okay next up we have the real crowning
crowning piece of this whole thing which
i'm very excited about i have never had
enough space to own a racing wheel
before now i do
[Music]
she's a big boy
here we go voila
the logitech g923 racing wheel for pc
and playstation i'm very excited about
this i also love that this isn't like a
huge gaudy setup like it looks like it's
gonna be pretty easy to just plug in and
i mean logitech have been making amazing
racing wheels for the longest time
so i feel like i'm in pretty good hands
here
this one is especially known for
delivering next-gen performance
and is known for its realism which is
part of its true force
hd force feedback feature the intent is
to experience ultra realistic racing
powered by true force feedback
let's open it up
this is this is
nice and compact i love it
okay
and this is lovely
it feels good catching paddles with your
paddle shifting
yeah this is nice this is real nice
it's also very sleek i don't just feel
like oh it's so well designed so this
will go right on my desk
pedals here
[Music]
very good
i love that they're all different type
of feedback as well just like a real car
very nice
we have a power cable here
and a power brick
let's assemble it all shall we they also
sent me a copy of project cars just to
try it out so i'm excited let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
it's happening
so this whole thing was actually really
easy to set up very simple didn't take
long at all um
it's ready let's do it
[Music]
use the track guide markers to guide you
around the track
the paint triangle markers are there to
tell you when and where to break
the yellow circle is an apex marker
aim to hit these corners
okay this feels really good
it's awesome
[Music]
[Music]
so
that was awesome good to see you out
there having fun
now catch your breath as it's time to
head to the street i'm not very good
your own set of wheels but this is my
first racing wheel it feels very
different to a controller
okay your first career let's get it off
to a good start
[Music]
okay this is feeling way better lance is
more my style to start with
oh no oh no oh no oh no okay okay okay
look at my good wow this feels so
different to what i'm used to
you can really feel the rumble too it's
very deep
like it's like i can feel like the
texture of the road if that makes sense
i feel like i'm slowly learning
it's slowly getting slightly easier
i'm definitely not downshifting right
though
[Music]
everyone is miles ahead of me but it's
okay
i am learning
[Music]
nope we made it we made it we made it
all right i had no walls it's my first
clean lap
it's wild i'm actually very good at
racing games now
i'm not i have a whole system
i gotta re-learn
which i'm excited about it feels really
good though like this grip feels really
nice the fabric's really nice like the
material feels really good in your hands
um it handles really well it doesn't
fight with you like i feel like a lot of
other racing wheels do like they just
like fight too much it becomes a little
bit too hard or certainly a lot harder
than a
real cars feel yeah i'm very into it and
i clearly have a challenge ahead of me
this is definitely an awesome upgrade to
my gaming stuff though a huge thanks to
best buy for sponsoring this video and
remember if you need anything to upgrade
your gaming setup whether it's pc
playstation if you want a racing wheel
like this one check out the link in the
description to find out more from best
buy they are a great go-to for gaming
i'll see you guys next time